- 歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
今天大盤跟桂買都跑去碰月線
欸 碰到還真的給它急拉一波
真的欸
因為今天早上我有請教艾倫
艾倫說希望開低走高
我就想 慢慢想吧你
可是因為這個
其實我比較在意的是這個量
量還是很小啊
對
所以我覺得
可是今天大盤
開低總高是拉快1000點
是
對 但成交量
就還是7000多億
所以我覺得應該是防守有餘
但進攻要再看個幾天
不錯了啦
因為這兩天有時候一早開盤
我們自己打開APP
預估量5000億
超過分 嚇一跳
然後想說
可能因為南部現在有災情
有放假 無心做股票這樣子
對
好 可是後來因為
可能盤面有一些震盪
所以量還是有拉到6、7000億以上
沒錯
不够吗
不够啊
怎么会够呢
我们现在四万多点呢
可是今天的收缴
有没有意义呢
因为我们之前常常说
涨上来了嘛
稍微回档一下
休息一下都是正常的
但是什么时候再攻
可能就要抓一下时机点了
没错
好 那我们来看一下
因为这礼拜很重要一件事情
明天的凌晨
灰达的财报公布了
以及这个财政部
美国的
它说要花一兆美元来救债市
是啊
有一句話叫做
關關難過
關關是誰
加油
關關難過
關關過
是
好 那今天的話
艾倫會幫大家
從各個族群的龍頭體檢
因為龍頭復甦
整個族群就有可能復甦
沒錯 一方面是有些龍頭
確實已經創新高了
回到了這個七月之前的龍光
但是有一些是一去不復返
所以我們這邊都會分別
根據有AI相關的一些龍頭
稍微幫大家看一下
技術面上的型態
當然我們一開始之前
还是跟大家看一下
这一个华许准备来Jackson Hall演说了
是一个全球央行的年会
那目前这个
我觉得这个也有可能是让整个行情
稍微比较温吞的一个状态
因为大家就是在等
到底会讲出什么东西
好 所以市场预期会不会有一些
FED的一个体制上的改革
那不会太着目于通膨跟货币决策的前景
就是一些前瞻指引
那这个其实应该就确定了
还有另外一个目前来说
他們也有一點生不了息的
一個尷尬情況
就是美債殖利率
不管是10年起 20年還是30年起
全部都是創下了一個
近幾年來的新高
尤其是30年起的
是的 金融海嘯以來的新高
那就有點尷尬了
那尷尬到什麼程度呢
尷尬到這個貝森特最近也有說
有一個進兆美元的銀彈
要準備回購美債9月9號開始
這個原本是要回購20億
那現在可能一次要40億
Double
对 为了就是要干嘛
为了就是要压这个债券的殖利率
好 那债券殖利率呢
为什么他们要压
因为目前的美国政府
已经是财政赤字了
对 那这一些呢
美债呢 时间到要付利息
那就是美国政府要付
所以呢 他如果利率越高
那当然付出去的钱越多
所以他不希望殖利率越来越高
但相对的 如果是这样子的话
那滑雪就很难升息
因为你的基准利率越高
美债殖利率就会跟着越来越高
而且他们后来都发新还旧
那新的就越來越
指定率越來越高
沒錯 那這個其實也蠻有趣的就是
其實我覺得這件事情
就是變相的QE
因為你回購債券回來
你就是向市場出錢
給錢 對 所以到時候
其實9月之後
我覺得我覺得行情
當然我們說基本面很好
但我覺得會有熱錢效應
所以我覺得今年第四季
應該值得關注
因為除了基本面好
要賣夢之外
錢每次都會有40億進來
所以我覺得是值得注意的
當然就變成是說華許
就有点进退两难了
因为我觉得它有点生不了息
虽然它讲的蛮硬派的
对 可是它应该
我觉得反而是不生息不降息的机会
下半年是提高的
就让它hold在那里
没错 打太极
对 你就自己慢慢弄
我就不生息也不降息
好 那再来另外一个就是这个
国会女股神
裴若熙
没错 重压这个B1
还有这个Intel
所以大家如果有兴趣的
可以去看高丽
因为高丽跟Blue Energy是有合作的
是直接这样子连
那看Intel的話呢
Intel的話可能看看聯電
看看矽晶元吧
我們就自己可以幻想一下
不然就開付委託啦
去買B1或者是買Intel
而且他們除了買現股之外
有買全
好 再來我們看一下
剛剛講到的就是
可能今年下半年
應該說不是下半年
第四季開始
第三季尾 第四季出
會有熱錢出來
但是我們在7月這波行情
散戶呢
錢反而是熱錢出脫
M1B跟M2
是的 出現了一個死亡交叉
對
就熱錢開始下滑了
沒錯
這個就會是一年以上的一些
可能定存等等
比較不能馬上隨手動用的資金
對 那兩個都是下滑的
但是下滑的過程中
這一個卻是比它來的低
所以就出現死亡交叉
沒有錯 死亡交叉應該是
這應該是股災以來首次
就是去年 去年以來首次
所以目前來說
其實成交量降低
一部分也有是
散戶進就可能不完了
因為成交量確實這幾波
降得非常的快
所以可能前面那一波反彈
做一些縮手
譬如說可能停損
或是回成本
看不懂
那我就後面可能也不想玩了
所以可能會觀望一陣子
因為我看到這句話播
以後去年11月有降下來
今年3月有降下來
就每一次散戶被燙到
都有降下來
所以七月降下來蠻正常的
可是這個M1B跟M2
這個就比較異常了
因為它一年多以來
第一次出現這個死亡交叉
就市場的熱錢在退潮
沒錯 所以我們也只能期待一下
貝昇德如果跟著開始回購
有沒有一些熱錢在慢慢跑出來
它這個錢很重要
所以我們稍微注意一下
資金確實是有在退潮的
這應該是蠻明確的
好 再來我們看到了
就是大盤的狀態了
我們剛剛提到沒有量
確實你看這邊
這邊是盤子
開始盤子
這裡成交量也一口氣
直接從兆元的量
直接降到現在
有6000億就蠻厲害的
少好多
是的
貴馬也是一樣
這一波下來
成交量也是一路的慢慢下降
那我們來看到大盤
今天我們剛剛有提到
開梯走高進千點
那進千點的狀態
再配上這個量
我也只會把它歸類在就是
底部有人會做防守
但是你要直接
这样子去一个垫高的行情
我觉得成交量至少要8以上
当然就是能够来到一兆以上
那当然是最好
所以目前来说这个量
就会变成是跌
也跌不到哪里去
但是涨呢也容易开高走低
所以就会变成是
就看个股表现了
尤其成交量变少
个股的表现延续性
又变得不太好
因为大家钱就这么少
那我今天炒完这一档
我隔天可能就直接换档
可能赚个10% 15%
短视经历一点点
有赚我就跑
直接跑下一档
所以現在股票是難操作的
這個應該大家體感是滿明確的
可是大盤還是要給他一點信心
這裡拉第一段
開始這邊震盪
我們在44200
對44200這邊打了兩隻腳
這裡一隻
所以這個地方剛剛提到的這個數字
然後再加上哪裡
再加上月線
今天撐住耶
對 月線關卡撐住
是的
所以這個短線我們觀察的支撐
就是44,200再加上月線的雙重支撐
均線跟K棒給的支撐
這兩個地方守兩次
這裡也守一次
那再來呢
你行情要去墊高
除了我們剛剛量要粗一點之外
我們這個小平台先做突破
因為這五天呢
其實你一眨眼回來看
在原點
今天很悲觀
隔天又很樂觀
結果呢
在隔天又很悲觀
然後回頭一看
怎麼原地不動
就在這個區間內做震盪
對 所以目前來說
这里如果能够做突破
带量攻击
那我觉得这个高点
就很允许做突破了
所以我们现在要等的是
进攻的讯号
防守是OK的
但是目前可能还没有
明确的进攻讯号
等于现在证明有在守
对 所以这样很好啊
就至少不用怕跳水嘛
我们现在也在等美股的表现
因为不是我们那样说
美股也那样说
大家都在等一下看辉大
有没有一些激情出来
那贵买也是一样
这里也是越线越线
那也是前低
盘中都跌破了
但收买有散回来
我觉得都还可以
所以贵买是这个地方要突破
上市是这个地方要突破
才有机会有一个新的行情
看有没有办法去延伸出来
不管是大盘还是贵买都一样
所以这是我们要观察的
几个支撑跟压力
给大家讲清楚
好 再来看到台积电
台积电今天很猛
今天拉50块
开低走高50块
最后会拉尾盘跟它也有关系
是的
台积电今天要站回全部均线
所以我们上次说
你跌破全部均线你不要紧张
但你站回全部均线
你也不用太兴奋
因為高點要做突破
才是行情的延伸
那低點要做跌破
它才會是空方行情的延伸
所以目前就在區間震盪
尤其這個成交量
也都是持續萎縮的
所以就等一個方向了
跟大盤一樣
我們要等一個方向
好 我們看點刺激的吧
光寶可
因為剛剛那些都在橫盤
對
這是創新高的
是的
今天還在創新高
沒錯
光寶可
好厲害 快300塊了
那個時候開了一個漂亮的
這個
好數字出來
是不是
看点开心的
没错
然后就一口气来到前高
在这边做震荡
晃了大概两三周
昨天涨停
今天呢
今天原本震荡很大
今天其实开高是被灌蛮重的
然后尾盘大家整个行情一好
它就跟着收到一个相对最高点
所以这边是第一段
那这边有一个整理
那整理在昨天做突破
今天继续做延伸
所以虽然看起来像在追
但其实是一个整理以后的转折
就是盘整转多头
那我觉得后续还可以再观察一下
高价股有穿壶
中架股有保科
好
那还有吗
可以了
火种没有灭
那火种没有灭的情况
刚刚艾伦有讲到
现在是有防守的
就要等上攻
当然美国挥达
还有这个Gickson Hall
讲的利率的决策
会是一个很重要的观察指标
下一段节目
我们干脆就
几个产业的龙头帮大家看
因为如果有人冲出去
那整體產業就有可能衝出去
等一下來盤點喔
好 來吧
我們來看一下最近這個股價
非常辛苦的回答
連續漆黑
對
這一片漆黑
但是你不覺得
它就像是一個成熟的倒碎嗎
就你說這樣向下彎嗎
重點是人家前面還打WD
然後談上來就
不知道很奇怪
就以前都是
開完財報開始跌
這個一次是財報之前開始跌
我跟你講一個好消息
根據統計啊
財報前面開始跌啊
財報開完還是會跌
好的 謝謝
所以我們就看這邊
財報公布完會不會破底這樣
是不是要這樣分析嗎
也不是啦
就是通常會蹲一下
然後就會上去了啦
對啦
那看回答有沒有辦法
來一個利多
因為前幾天
華盛軍還有飛來台灣
快閃喔
又趕快回去要主持這個財報會議了
沒錯
另外則是Varubin能不能如期放量
好 就是Q4
目前來說好像這一季
還是認為數字會到
只是它往後遞眼嘛
但數字不變
好 那這個是後續可以去觀察
再來還有一個
就是大家對於
回答AI央行的疑慮
它能不能講得清楚一點點
是的 所以這個是我們後面兩天
可以去觀察
回答的財報的部分
那當然等數字出來
我們就來看一下市場怎麼反應囉好顯然這一次AI央行的是比較新的就跟當年大家在解釋中國到底能不能出口一樣可能它有一個好的解釋市場就會比較容易理解了
沒錯
好 那我們今天
今天CPO是很強的
好
CPO我們之前特別有聊過
以形態來說真的是蠻厲害的
當時是幫大家找
沒有漲那麼多的
因為像聯亞都已經在天上了
那落後的其實像零化音全新
也有在漲
華星光那時候真的很抵擋
是 涨了四成啊
沒錯
其實今天滿有
這麼猛喔
很猛啊
OK 好
OK好
今天601啊
今天601
回到600關了
其實前面挑戰三次
都沒有站上
那今天是有站上600關
好 那不管怎麼樣
其實今天的整個CPU
在11點多的時候
有足群性的起漲
今天是很晚才發動
沒錯 其實不只他們
光盛 上全
冬點光電 潛頂
那一些其實都有
拉一個大紅可以出來
但这种是不是比较像隔日冲的手法
有可能
所以明天大家稍微注意一下
那当然如果隔日冲换手成功
它还是会有高点
只不过就稍微关注一下
这个比较偏无尾盘在拉的
比较有机会是
明天开高会被倒下来
明天如果开高大家就不要追了
当然如果震荡完
又开始有一些下引线
还是怎么样的形态
那再做介入就好
不过CPU确实
今天是盘面的亮点之一
那不过今天我们要跟大家讲的
就是这几个都是
今年或者说去年都非常夯的一个族群
那我们今天来帮大家看一下
这些个股的形态
现在有没有什么样不同的变化
好 有记忆体
ABF CCL 封测被动元件
其实还很多啦
我还想要讲比如说散热
对 散热人家启鸿创新稿
因为太多啦
这里面的形态完全大不相同
我们先来看的就是记忆体的乃亚科
它很厉害了吧
很厉害
世界级的乃亚科
是的
南亚科在前一阵子
这一波反弹的行情
是有创下历史新高的
有的是可能连反弹30%都不到
没有那么过分
50%都不到的
好 南亚科在近期
进入了一个高档的震荡
因为你可以发现
像是美光也在高档
做一些震荡了
不过像是三星海力士
这一波其实都是反弹
快半三腰而已
南亚科是可以直接创新高的
所以南亚科的走势
确实这一波是强势的
近期当然我们就等一个
有机会等一个新的买点
因为它目前守住了这个缺口
在高档做区间震荡
那不过五日均跟十日均线
也在昨天刚跌破
刚跌破过程中
这边如果能够守好
那我会觉得挑战高点
挑战高点
这边再看有没有机会
拉出一个新的趋势
所以我觉得其实今天
这根就很漂亮
对因为今天是站回全部均线
那碰前低站回全部均线
我觉得就很不错
所以明天可以看一下
有没有可以延续性可以拉出来
这是南亚科
這個是強勢的反彈AI股
好 再來我們看到的是
這一波也是強勢的反彈AI股
就是新興
ABF栽辦
這個族群是強勢中的強勢
沒錯 波動很大
是的 新興這一波反彈上來
也是創下了歷史新高
當然因為它歷史新高
這邊是沒有創下來的
因為南電跟景碩這邊是有創高的
不過今天南電跟景碩的形態也好看
等一下 沒有等一下
大家回去自己看
因為我只有講新興而已
好 大家自己開框
就是另外两档也好看
对对对对
因为其实这一次星星
下来修正的幅度比较轻
景硕跟南电
它是回到了季线的位置
但今天同步碰季线
都跟星星一样开地走高
有拉长下引线
而且是红K
重点是量还有放出来一点点
所以我觉得景硕南电
大家都可以一起进来看
那星星这一波呢
一样在这边反弹的时候
也是进入了一个整理
那这里打两只脚
这里守住大红K的低点
然后今天站回10日均
如果明天站回5日均线
其实我觉得就有机会
在这边看有没有一个
创历史新高的机会
所以欣欣目前形态上
非常的漂亮
我觉得是好看的
大家可以多关注的
再来我们看的就是台光店
台光店这一波也创下历史新高
但这一波最强的其实是三哥
连帽
今天还涨停板
很厉害
这一波反弹比较弱的是台药
二哥
二哥大概反弹
因为它前面其实
那一段是他涨最凶
那他反弹的幅度大概到这里
就是大概一半左右
那台光电呢
他一样也是有创新高后的压回
所以有创新高后的个股
其实我觉得都是好事
那只不过回测看深或不深
那接下来他来到了月线附近
今天有拉一个红K起来
我觉得还差一点点
大家可以看五日均线有站回来
再考虑要不要做介入就好了
也就是说低点有手
那站回五日均线是进攻讯号
到时候如果你有做介入
这个低点就会是跌破后你的停顺点
然后我觉得就相对好抓
因为你看这边
都不会是值得关注的讯号
每天都是往右下方移动
那今天难得拉一个脚
看能不能往右上方移动
如果有那今天的低点
就可以视为短线的重点支撑
因为刚刚有提到整体来说
应该是有防守对不对
所以它到月线如果没有跌破
应该也算是
我们在操作股票上面的
一个支撑点到了吗
没有错
而且我觉得它这一波
也没有到跌非常重
雖然也是很大的幅度一起勤抠
但是人家是創新高后压回
那个又不太一样
不太一样有创过高了
没错
好那再来我们来看到的就是
比较牛一点点的风测长
也代表整体的风测
事实上这波反弹上来也比较牛
是的
弹了一段之后就开始横盘了
没错
我们看到了基本上七月的股票
大概都是涨这样
对 大家涨一样
但是反弹的状态就不太一样
你看瑞瑞光现在反弹的幅度
大概就接近50%
所以其实它没有弹得很凶
那目前来说
弹上来到这个地方之后
也开始在这边做横盘震荡
也就是说它下也下不去
但是你要再向上垫高
目前好像资金似乎不在这里
但是呢
如果以日月光啊
晶圆店呢
可能下半年的营收表现来讲
其实我觉得会偏委屈
它的股价啦
对
股价偏委屈
但目前资金动能确实不在这里
所以如果你要买像这种形态
就是日月光嘛
应该大家也不怕它倒嘛
对不对
难听一点
也是這樣嘛
世界第一大風色場
對 那目前來說
就是一個大的區間在這裡
所以要真的
真的有行情去做啟動
那當然這個高點要去做一個突破
那目前來說是沒有去做突破的
但低點都有在做防守
今天也是一樣 持續守好
那就是等一個站回全部均線
然後站回高點
那這個行情才有機會
沿來一波爆發性的成長
股價才有爆發性的一個機會
他們可能跟台積電對不對
供應鏈例如設備也是這樣子
都比较牛皮一點
所以如果台衣店今天有一個
比較明確的發動
可能整體供應鏈
就會有比較明顯往上走
整體Colors應該就有機會動一步
新進風中Colors也是供不應求
沒錯 但是目前似乎
資金不想買這一塊族群
可能去買海了
好 再來我們看到最辛苦的
相對辛苦的就國聚
不曉得在上面的朋友還好嗎
因為長了
但真的談不回
不要说远点
可能一半都会点点吃力的情况
它又下去回测500块了
没错我们刚看到了
最差的状态应该是日月光
但日月光也站回了季线
但是国距连距离季线的位置
都还有一定的乖离
那这一波反弹从400多弹到600多
其实也还好
对啊我们这边是
1220下来的
这边膝盖展嘛
那膝盖展弹了大概这样弹起来
可能连这边的40到50%都不到
也就是说呢
那其实大家可以蛮明确的注意到
国具的走势在这一波反弹是比较弱势的
那比较弱势该怎么办
没能怎么办
如果你是买在800以上900以上的
那你这边也不太会卖了嘛
那就只能等了
等到什么时候
等到哪一天
开始又有新的一个题材去运转的时候
因为像我也有听到有人说法是
国具是涨价题材
是
主动元件
被动元件 实音元件都涨价题材
那还有像PCB这些都是涨价题材
材料类
那这一波涨价题材
最受惠的是谁
是记忆体
所以记忆体的股价
它如果没有一个延续性拉出来
其他涨价题材
可能延续性要拉出来的
的激励也会更低
所以记忆体一定要先抢
那后面整个涨价题材才会有
大家透过这样的方式去找
有没有一起涨价的利多
去反映在其他族群身上
所以国际目前来说
以题材来讲可能还差一点点
那以基本技术面上来讲
這邊回測到前滴附近
如果有守好
頸線能夠做突破
這邊的大底部才會有確立的迅逃
那到時候看要怎麼去做一個
形態上的轉強
所以目前來說
觀察的就是這個高點的位置
何時能做突破
才有機會迎來一波新的反彈的契機
是 因為漲價看記憶體
記憶體平均是漲了大概有四倍之多
所以能夠續漲其他的漲價題材
才有辦法延續
再來就是升級的題材
可能升級的題材就是看PCB為主了
但被动元件在升级上面
是没有像PCB这么
这么样的明显
所以这些都是要
一并来做观察的
那如果需要今天节目
所有的图卡资料
我们有免费提供
但是要希望大家订阅一下
我们赵华艾伦说的
YouTube频道
我们会放在首页的贴文栏
广告回来我们有一个大来宾
我们这个戏称他是
台股最强散户
而且他要来跟大家解释
为什么有那么多的关键分点
這些哥們到底在做什麼
現在在買什麼
真的叫做一個主力大揭秘
待會兒來聊
歡迎回到趙花
還有人說
好 我們台股現在
有所謂的第四大法人
你有聽說嗎
有 現場有一位
幹嘛直接破題
不好意思
像最近在窒息量
你会觉得主力大户其实没事做
其实我觉得
因为它那个波动变比较小
或者说它延续性不好
那可能以波段来讲
我觉得就会比较喜欢停看听
但是我们这位这一个地势大法人
可能也蛮喜欢这种上下波动
单日的那种上下波动盘
是 因为我们都觉得现在盘很黏
可能散户朋友觉得无聊
大户可能也会觉得无聊
但不是
大户其实还蛮忙的
蛮有聊的是不是
对 就是人家之所以会成功
他之所以會成功的原因
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的全鎮小哥
嗨
有沒有好
我們今天幫小哥取了一個綽號
叫台灣傳奇散戶
但是我覺得你已經不是散戶了
你已經是大戶了
會不會這樣子講太那個
太對付你了
對啊 這樣寫
有台灣兩個字都覺得很驕傲
因為最近是所謂的量比較低
6000多億的成交量
那很多人都覺得說
可能大戶都不玩了
但是我每天看小哥的臉書
IG他玩得很開心
沒錯 對
對我們而言蠻好玩的
是 這種盤也蠻好玩的
你這邊有一個slogan
精準獵殺 鎖定主力新目標
積極分點 隔日沖 急速獲利
這是拍什麼電影嗎
這蠻好玩
因為我們多空都會做
例如說遇到波段做多的大戶
就跟啊
像大立光、川湖
這個都是很厲害的大戶在買
這種就跟單
遇到隔日沖會大買的
隔天大部分都大賣
那就跟著他們一起賣就好了
所以多空都蠻好玩的
所以小哥每天還是很忙
很忙之餘也會來告訴我們
到底在這樣的量裡面
這樣算自息量嗎
還是搞不好會有其他的量更低
主力到底在忙著買什麼
幫我們講故事
好 那我們首先來講
這個台股的波段主力
那波段主力呢
通常都是買一段時間叫波段像這個三多哥三多哥這個代表作大立光他在高雄嘛对不对对 凯基三多
代表作我们之前在理财团秀
也讲过蛮多次
大立光买很多
最近呢
大立光有点获利了结
不过卖的也不多
后面又去买了川湖
每次川湖大买的那一天
就会卖大立光
你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼
交割金不夠嗎
比較貴一點
所以大陸跟我們一樣
也是有交割款不夠的困擾
那這個三多哥
我覺得最近算是票房的保證
票房保證
因為他大力光好像蹲蠻久的
蹲蠻久的
大概賺了也快一倍了
川五八千多買
跌到六千多
想說這次該不會吃憋了吧
一萬五
所以真的很厲害
不過他們到底不知道依據的信心從何而來
因為感覺上跌下來
也沒有在做停損這件事
沒有 我們散戶要停損
倒叫布局
口袋深分批布局
是
散戶口袋潛了
後面沒得布局只好停損
所以不太一樣
好 但三多哥看中的
好歹是這種EPS高速成長的
高價高全值股票
好 那還有其他的
像這個永寧哥其實
勇宁哥的波段比較短一點
他有時候兩天
有時候三天
有時候就可能長一點
有時候可能到一個禮拜
像最近他抄底的被動元件
就比較長一點
他現在還抱著嗎
他現在大部分還是出了
那談一段時間他就輸掉了
那被動他抄的那個點
其實很漂亮
因為為什麼這麼說
因為他抄點跟我抄點一樣
自己貼近一下
鼓力就抓住
其實蠻開心的
我在超完的那一天
去看一下分店
永齡哥跟我同時燕進場
超誰
華西科
華西科是連續點
因為那時候又是
儲置股又儲量
所以其實大戶看的角度
都蠻類似的
所以永齡哥
我覺得他的交易的邏輯
還有他每次買的那個點
我覺得都很漂亮
这个也蛮值得研究的
最近的代表作是全新
对啊 这个全新
这个他三天4000万就落袋了
那最近的他比较短一点
像全新的比较厉害
一买完之后
可定又涨停又涨停
那这种也蛮常见的
所以他买的时候
还不一定是只有一根涨停
有可能是两根涨停
好 这个是土城永宁吗
原大土城永宁
是不是他也做过航运
有
它只要是热门的题材
他都有玩过
所以但它比较短
短一点点
短的波段
我们以前讲说不只隔日冲
可能三日冲这样子
可能三日冲一周冲这样
还有一位
还有一位是康永哥
这就比较长的波段
最经典代表作就是2016年的大宇芝
现在已经改名了
那时候买100块
卖在260
等到买完之后
股票北上走一段
高档卖完之后
股票南下走一趟
所以你跟着他做
这大雨之260块
你可能可以赚到300块
就上面赚一段150
底下赚一段又150
多空都做的话
所以他算是很大量
而且蛮厉害的
到现在为止
他也是持续的布局股票
这些哥会找你吗
不會
你為什麼都在外面講我這樣
也不會因為你講換分點
也不會
這幾個我們都講很多年了
都沒換
有些比較短線的他會換
有些還會怎樣你知道嗎
有些你都觀察他了
然後他的波段會變隔日重
那很在乎你
對啊 這種比較害怕一點
因為你都覺得他是波段
然後他買了你跟著買
結果呢
他買的隔天是要到貨的
那這個有一些歌是這樣
我就不方便在這邊講了
不方便把它講出來
好 我們剛剛舉的這些例子
其實股票也有幫我們列出來
而且最重要是他們到底現在在幹嘛
現在在幹嘛
首先我們來看一下
這個大力光
它之前的位置
真的是非常低
這邊嗎 在地方
對 那個位置超低
但它第一檔大買的時候
我們就有在理財談就講了
所以这个一定要留意
那买完之后
他还赔钱
我们那时候来说
这个大户赔钱的时候
你不赔
东山再起你是谁啊
就后面真的是东山再起
2000多块涨到5000多块
那我们可以看一下
到5000多块呢
他有大卖吗
他有卖
但是并不是出托的那种卖
所以呢
對於大立光而言
他們的目標價不是這個價錢
他是先獲利入袋一些
他是獲利入袋拿去繳川武
繳川武
你看你可以看到
其實川武大買的時候
就是在大立光大賣的時候
交割金不夠
所以那川武也蠻厲害
這個大買之後是8線多塊
那前波7月份的股災
川武又跌了
跌到6千多
他也沒賣
那最近川普這個漲上來
太大幅的加碼
所以這檔股票
對三多哥而言
應該這個價位是沒有滿足它的
好 那它現在就是主要這兩檔高價
它就沒有再去布局其他的
比較沒有
三多哥還蠻專一的
對 蠻專二的
不要中二就好了
這樣子兩檔專二
所以大家也可以參考一下
三多哥布局 零股也可以
對 他下次大買我一定跟的
因為他這兩把都很漂亮
是 而且下跌的時候
剛剛有講還蠻有勇氣
繼續攤平
那這邊的話是講康永哥
對 康永哥這個年代比較久遠一點
這以前叫大宇之
現在叫光聚晶電
對 那我們可以看到
那個圖在左邊
在2016年買過一波
其實他大宇之買過蠻多波的
所以他就是大宇之的关键分点
那这几波其实买卖点都蛮漂亮
就是都低买高卖
他还蛮密集在买卖的
对 他就买了
然后一个波段然后卖掉
那跌了又买 又卖掉
所以这个大宇之他玩的蛮精彩的
就是当年算是一个代表座
对
玩到人家如果改名字
改名字
对啊 我就想说
这么康永哥这样买的股票
应该是蛮优秀的
小巴後面改名的
那你看後面這一段空投
康永哥就賣掉了
賣光光了
所以康永哥可能看到什麼東西
他就先出脫
後面空投就沒有他了
我還記得康永哥以前做過一張統證
因為那時候我們兩個在做
歌有酬必爆的時候聊的
對 照我來好記性
統證他也是買的很多
而且統證那點也很漂亮
我們也是靠統證賺不少
這種波段的大哥
買的股票
只要是低檔他賠錢的時候
都是好買一點
因為大家都可能會覺得
會不會是你看錯
後面就發現
他又有想辦法
是你看太短
是我錢不夠
是人家看比較長這樣
人家看比較長
好
最近買的是波城
波城從低檔開始佈局
你看從10塊錢這邊也買蠻多的
後面在高檔
在三四十塊
他也持續布局
10塊買到40塊再買
到現在這個位置也沒有賣
所以也不知道要看到哪邊
不過這個博城目前在一個
大幅的大帶寬的平行通道
所以各位你要買的話
買在下通道比較安全
到了上通道你就不要追了
然後上通道之後你追
那跌下來
你就想說人家康永哥都還持有著
你到底要不要賣
心裡很掙扎 很糾結
不如馬來下通道
馬來下通道你就不會有這些想法
不過康宏科的布局
有說是相當長久 很長
他也有過很多案例是
布局很長 後面沒動
也有啦 也有
這樣聽起來我們又害怕起來
真的康宏科跟那個
山多哥比起來
這個山多哥的打擊率比較高
目前是二個打擊
兩隻安打
沒錯
比較厲害
好 就是卡永哥最近在布局博生
大家參考
那這個巨響是另外一個分別
巨響另外一個
這個也是最近網友問我的
他問我說
小哥你有沒有看到巨響有個敦然哥
不是國泰敦然喔
是另外一個敦然
國泰敦然據說是散戶最大宗的聚集地
我今天聽到一個消息
我覺得蠻正經的
什麼東西
聽說很多主力都改去國泰敦然
眼人耳目
對啊 因為
國外斷展他就很多散戶
那我藏在一個很多散戶之間
大家就不知道我是主力了
所以還有用這招
蠻厲害的
難怪現在大家覺得
散戶變聰明了是不是這個原因
有可能 其實都是主幣
主力變散戶
對啊 所以這個有時候分點
講太多也好像也不太好
有時候這個主力會躲避一下
那這巨牆呢
敦南哥最近也是買蠻多的
那一樣他也是一個平行的通道
平行通道你就下通道再布局就好了
你不要去追在上通道
那不过有一天只要他开布林
往上走
可能就是另一波行情的开始
现在下布林附近
对 现在是在一个震荡的过程
震荡吃货中
那为什么我不能买在布林通道的下方
等于减便宜
可以啊
我买在下通道比较好
但是就可能要等
等超跌
或者你可以区间操作
因為他現在這個貸寬也到2-30%了
也還可以區間操作
好 這是統一敦南哥
也算是一個波段高速
對 他也是蠻厲害的
那這邊的話
也幫我們乾脆就做了一張表
來統整最近主力大戶
可能比較鎖定的標的
後來看那個表發現
好像不是只有AI股
現在開始擴散到傳產類了
因為AI股很多都漲多
或者是有很多套勞賣壓的問題
那所以傳產股相對而言比較乾淨一點
籌碼比較乾淨
股價比較低一點
你看一下這幾檔
這都是主時 主五有在買的
那怪零連線呢
除了像這個台聖科比較高以外
聯電稍微高以外
還有盟利比較高
那有的都沒有怪零連線很多
那這邊有投信聯買的天數
還有投信買超占成交量的%數
像這些呢
我們喜歡主投買的股票
就是主力有在買
投信有在買
主投買的股票呢
籌碼比較安定
當然主力這邊還是
既然是專訪嘛
還是再幫大家講一下
5天跟10天的籌碼集中度
10以上就已經非常高了
對
這10天的籌碼集中度
到10這個數字
就很不錯了
其實好像前幾天
其實小哥也有在達人秀講說
現在航運
其實籌碼集中度超級高
四五十 這非常誇張
所以這個抽到集中度
我們就這樣子看
好 那我們來看一下這幾檔神達來了一檔最沒風浪的就是神達沒有風浪他根本就一條直線躺在地上對啊 像這種就是主力緩慢吃貨中
你看主力有買外資有買
投信前陣子有買
這看起來是調整的買盤
那主力最近有買
所以我覺得這種緩慢吃貨中
然後直利率也還漂亮的股票
像這種就是一個逢第一步舉的好機會
可是這個就不會太無聊嗎
會有點無聊
因為你看看他貸寬
他貸寬非常的窄
隨時要表態的意思
貸寬很窄
貸寬很窄就是平常政府都很小
那有個方法就是
你就買個零股
買個零股也才90塊
然後放在自選
假如有一天你看他漲8%
進去
因為漲8%就是發動了
那時候就把一股換成一張這樣
不要因为涨了那8%
觉得错过什么
那本来是发动的讯号
对对对发动讯号
因为他吃这么久
会有一天发动
好这个是
虽然躺很久
很多朋友觉得他很牛
但是搞不好一发动
就不可收拾
是啊
再来看这2464的蒙利
蒙利这个是有在动的
他这波动度已经上升了
那有在动
你看从118到208
一下也涨了一倍
涨了一倍之后的回挡
然后月线往上升
這邊回檔到上升月線是個好賣點
這是其一
那第二呢我們就要看
這個主力在回檔的時候有沒有大賣
那主力在回檔的時候沒有大賣
沒有大賣呢
月線就確認是個好賣點
有創過歷史新高又下來
那主力又沒有走
沒有走 對
而且這種下來
只要只下來一次就談了
就是好的買點
假如下了一次又下一次
那就不要买了
下了太多次了
如果没有主力的那个财力
就先不要买了
对 就不要买
好 现在下一个
下一个圆东营
圆东营最近的筹码
你看一路的往上
所以看起来也不错
而且算是低价的银行股
筹码也蛮顶的
最近主力有在买
因为富邦建营上下
挂牌以来的新高
所以这种小型的银行股
搞不好会跟
不要小看金融股
母雞帶小雞
對
好 下一個
新復發
怎麼可能 贏劍
贏劍 我們覺得怎麼可能
房市好像也沒回溫
對啊 可是他最近
有點開布林的樣子
開布林
是不是因為高股息
有可能 他質率真的蠻高的
是
他有點開布林
然後主力買開布林
不過新復發還真的是牛
即便他開布林
也是開得很牛皮的樣子
那邊開步你可能一次都
3% 5%
他開步你可能就1% 2%這樣
這樣開是不是
也是開啦 緩慢的開
那主力增進也是有買
接下來寶瑞
遮了一身
因為每次小哥說寶瑞
我就會說寶瑞就不會動啊
不會動喔
生技股裡面以前是股王
現在你看藥荒要操作到什麼程度了
小哥就說動啦
動啦 創高啦
你看今天473了
什麼473
印象裡面是800塊的股票
我那時候講是比較低檔
三四百的時候
也是啊
最近也是緩慢的這個動上來了
這個沒有動很快
但慢慢的也創高
到底有沒有
因為寶瑞的話我們說是這個
由藥品代工的網
支網台積電
藥品類的台積電
可是真的是一蹶不振
就是股價很溫吞
不過創高就是好事情
因為創高代表上面的賣壓比較少
那最近主力有買
因為投信
千兩天突然大買
真的耶 買三天
對啊 那投信買股票
也不是隨便能買的
已經有做過研究了
那他又是主力買投信買
又有波段權證
所以看起來應該是不錯
因為我實在印象很深
是權證是有時間價值的
可是有一個權證大戶
就非常愛他
就一直壓住在他身上
好 看起來可能有機會
機會看來
因為投信也跑來了
符合主投賣
那這邊的話
小哥每天為什麼很忙
是因為他偶爾也會看看這些
可日衝
跟著做所謂的極速獲利攻略
這邊有想要做短線的朋友想學的
因為我們都教大家做廠
死爆
可是應該也會有人想要做
短線一點的小哥來教學
好 那我們可以這樣講
你做股票
很多人做股票都做錯了
他早上一開盤
他會想買股票
到了尾盤之後
他就在想說
我今天到底是要
來做當沖還是要做股東
通常都是有賺做當沖
沒賺做股東
漸漸的就成為很多加工資的股東
就變成褲子
褲子就一堆
怎麼都是賠錢的
那就是他做錯方向
其實一找
一找其實是要
找時間賣股票的
你有一些褲子
找盤是讓你賣股票的
今天例外
今天是開地走高
但开机走告盘其实不多
那到了尾盘
你是要找机会买股票的
尾盘买股票早上卖掉
那这就是隔日冲
那这些隔日冲
他们很多都是去看今天谁最强
他去买很多
那隔天他就会卖股票
那有的人想说
那这样子我就去空隔日冲的股票好吗
也不一定
因为有些隔日冲的股票
他都是很强势的
那你空很强势的股票
你的期望只是低的
所以你空很強勢的股票
你要記得那個型態
型態很重要
假如每天都跳空一支線漲停
你就不要空了
像最近有一根有一檔股票
每天都一支線一支線
買不到
你說分拆過後的那一檔
分拆過後 對
那個你就不要追了
就是覺得不要追
那你也不要去空它
尤其是漲停沒有打開
你覺得不要空
因為漲停沒打開
你空可能可能又有漲停
所以空難懂
打開了 那
那個肉可能有點多
哈哈哈哈
好 所以期待在喔
那這個祕記喔
你曉得是買到隔日聰
買到漲停的股票
隔日聰有大買的股票
你要記得喔
漲停就續爆
我也想要漲停
對啊 就是你今天
可能看到7-8%
盤中看到7-8%很強
你想說要不要買一下
看隔日聰會不會進來鎖
可以啊 你就買個8%
停損你可以設個6%
頂多賠2%而已
他假如鎖漲停
恭喜你
留著
漲停就續爆
有漲停我們當然就續爆
那隔天
但是哪來的漲停
隔天繼續漲停繼續爆
不要賣
你不要說賺一根就醜
有的隔衝買的股票
我常看到那種
五根漲停 六根漲停
我也想
所以這種
跟著隔衝鎖漲停
漲停就續爆
那假如這檔股票
它已經開始走空投趨勢了
那什麼叫空投趨勢呢
就是月線已經下彎了
這種空投趨勢呢
這種你要記得
漲停的隔天你要賣
我們用幾個案例來看一下
首先來看全新
全新呢各位看
這個前波到一個高點
後面走有點空投
最近是做一個反彈
那你看這個隔聰
土城永寧
友林哥就很厲害
買完之後還漲停兩天
所以友林哥在造山運動的時候
其實他蠻常去玩的
那造山運動
左邊是造山運動
右邊就走下山了
在下山的時候
你看到友林哥大買的隔天
記得趕快賣股票
他就做得很短了
做很短
對啊 好
來看下一個
這個這邊是格衝
在最近常賺的一些股票
大部分都強盛鼓
凱基台北
凱基信義 凱基成中
對 代表凱基的軟體蠻好的
所以歌中喜歡用
對
那歌中其實也會用元大富邦
好 首先來看這個像合金
合金在高點照山頂的左邊
凱基台北
歌中就蠻常玩的
真的耶
那山頂的右邊也會玩
只是我玩的频率就减低了
那三迭的右边你看
只要大长虹
它可能就是一个大虹K
大虹K的隔天
这个拉高你要记得卖股票
你看这边就有一个
蛮经典的案例
也等于变难玩了
变难玩了
最近隔冲变难玩了
因为很多股票都已经在走下坡了
好
再来看下一个
像世维航
世维航这看起来是一个造山运动
噢
照山運動持續中
那什麼樣
什麼時候我們才確認
不是照山運動
就是月線殺兩次
是
現在還沒有月線殺兩次的狀況
那照山運動持續中
我們可以看到
這些隔衝分點
像凱基台北
他就會常常每天玩
對耶
今天買明天賣
那他這個節奏會讓他怎麼樣
紅K 黑K 紅K 黑K
那你就跟著他節奏玩
他買了
你跟著他買了
隔天早上你就先賣
黑黑下你又可以买
每天這樣玩
其實蠻開心的蠻有趣的
難怪很忙
真的很忙
像真頂 真頂也是一個
已經造山運動完了
造完了 三頂出現
你看三頂出現到現在都沒有
突過前高了
所以你看三頂出現之後的大買隔天
你都是要賣股票
凱基信義
他們現在也是有小小的買賣
小小買賣這可能都是散戶了
那像他們這種大戶一買就是500張
因為500張金額才夠
這個玩起來才有意思
好 現在看這個
連光也是最近蠻強的
凱基信義
連光最近也是有這個
隔衝的現象
是 好
那最後呢
還有利基電
利基電算是這個已經
這個山頂有點出現了
所以最近呢
最近這種大買隔天
你還是賣比較好
是 好
那最後呢是這義行
又是航運
又回到航運
義行看起來是
他不是真的航運
剛開始不是真的航運
但是他可能有別的提供
因為他股價太低了
是
他之前在高檔26塊
這個董事長拼聖報早上
聖報早上沒有股票了
對啊
現在又變成低檔
最近跟著航運稍微起來一點
是
所以現在看起來的話
大家又回頭集合在航運股的狀態
真的還蠻明顯
那會從AI跑到航運嗎
還是兩邊都會有人做
兩邊都會有人做
就輪流做
AI休息買航運
航運休息買AI
因為他們錢也不夠
也叫交割
那前一波這樣下殺的時候
你有聽到哪一些
主力分店有比較受傷嗎
有聽到一些少年股層受傷
就是很喜歡追強勢股的
那後面假如有些點位沒跑掉的話
捨不得停損就被人家砍掉了
因為他們很多都開槓桿的
所以江海是老的啦
對
是吧
沒錯
這些老分點都很大
應該不是說我吧
哥是小哥永遠的小哥
大家好
今天很謝謝小哥
幫我們解密了很多主力大戶
而且很多都是熟面孔
真的叫做經得起小哥的考驗
在達人秀
對不對
收視率這麼高的節目
然後大家也都知道了
結果他們就不換就是不換
對
照做給你們
優秀
對啊
我做窗戶你買得起嗎
哈哈哈哈
你跟得起嗎
哈哈
你跟啊這樣